Cory is in Virginia hi Cory welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hey thank you so
much for taking my call sure what's up
okay I just started listening about a
month ago to forget me here but I bought
a new truck last year I was debt-free
before the purchase I have about 40,000
still and I have about 25,000 in pre-tax
401k and that's my vested balance and
I'm currently contributing maximum
amount to a Roth I switched over I'm
wondering if I should use next year to
roll that traditional 401k over to a
Roth and not contribute any out of my
paychecks and pay the truck off as fast
as possible what's your household income
I make about 110 well good for you
okay thank you no I would not do it in
that order I see what you're doing and
your thinking is on the right track I
just would do it on a different order my
first order of business is just get the
truck paid off stop all investing
immediately oh yes all of it even if
there's a match everything get on a
budget and quit spending money and put
it all on the stupid truck and pay off
the stupid truck like in a year yeah
that that's kind of what I'm planning
this is incredible focused intensity for
a year
are you single understood yet there ah
that makes it even easier because all
you got to do is just look in the mirror
and go no you don't have to convince
anybody else you just got a guy at the
guy in the mirror he's your only problem
yeah I agree
Andy's your solution which is the good
news you make good money
you just made a stupid move with the
truck and it put you out of the
investing business for one year while
you get the truck paid off if you got
any money saved that is not in your
retirement accounts just my step one
okay so you already got baby steps going
which is baby step ones a thousand
dollars okay so now we're on the every
dollar budget we're gonna make every
dollar behave we're gonna stop all
investing temporarily hammer this truck
be done in one year then let's reopen
the equation finish the emergency fund
start baby step four which is 15% of
your income going into retirement
I would not convert your traditional to
a Roth until your house is paid off okay
because I want to use all your money in
the mean time 15% going into retirement
you'll get there and it just let it sit
there and grow it's not going anywhere
and it's going to create a little bit
more taxes because that growth is all
gonna be taxable but it's not gonna be
the in the world you'll get there pretty
quick because you're making really good
money and you now have a newfound plan
true yeah my thinking was I could
convert it and still hit my maximum
contribution next year yeah I wouldn't
fool with it now we just I would say
fifteen percent of your income going
into retirement when you get to your
baby step four you don't have kids
college so we're on to the house do you
own a home no not currently
okay if you're gonna save up and buy a
house we're gonna do it you know and
baby steps
three post baby step three somewhere in
there if you're gonna delay buying a
home for three or four more years and
you want to go after you are putting
fifteen percent of your income into
retirement if at that point you want to
go ahead and flip it you can because
that basically makes you at baby step
seven until you buy a house right
so because baby steps by saying that I'm
sorry sorry that's okay converting that
that would that count towards my yearly
contribution right no it does not it
doesn't affect your contribution at all
but it does create taxes here and you
don't need a tax bill right now you got
a forty thousand our truck bill right
okay and that's what I'm saying I want
to get that I wanna get the truck
knocked out get the emergency fund in
place start saving for retirement before
I create an extra tax bill that I don't
have to create all right but it is
advantageous to make that swap when you
can get to it but do it in that right
order